FIVE.
♪ ♪
JOE BIDEN HAS A BIG PROBLEM,
SOME DEMOCRATS ARE BUYING HIS
MALARKEY ON GARAGE GATE,
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS FOUND FIVE
MORE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN HIS
DELAWARE HOUSE AFTER THE
WHITE HOUSE SAID THE SEARCH WAS
COMPLETE, THAT'S IN ADDITION TO
THE ONES JOE SAID WERE SECURE IN
HIS GARAGE, RIGHT HERE WITH THE
PRIZED CORVETTES, ADAM SCHIFF
HAVING A HARD TIME DEFENDING,
BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE THE
WHITE HOUSE TRIED TO COVER THIS
UP.
>> I'M GLAD THAT THERE IS A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR THAT HAS BEEN
APPOINTED.
>> YOU ARE GLAD THERE IS A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
TO SPEAK THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ARE TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY, NO ONE IS ABOVE THE
LAW, SO I AM GLAD TO SEE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOING ITS
WORK.
>> IT CERTAINLY EMBARRASSING,
RIGHT?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE CONGRESS
TO ITS OWN ASSESSMENTS AND
RECEIVE AN ASSESSMENT FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY OF
WHETHER THERE WAS AN EXPOSURE TO
OTHERS OF THESE DOCUMENTS,
WHETHER THERE WAS HARM TO
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW THINGS ARE
BAD WHEN YOU LOSE ADAM SCHIFF,
EVEN THE MEDIA THINKS THAT THIS
TORPEDOES THE NOTION THAT HE IS
MR. CONFIDENCE.
>> THIS IS VERY, VERY BIG DEAL
POLITICALLY.
>> I DON'T THINK SITTING DOWN
AND HUNKERING DOWN AND JUST
ACTING LIKE IT IS NOT OUT THERE
IS A GOOD THING.
I THINK THAT THEY WILL GET CREAM
TO DOING THAT.
IF >> WHAT HAPPEN HERE WITH
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS REALY
AROSE AND UNDERMINES NOT JUST
THE MOMENTUM, BUT THE BRAND THAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN BUILDING
OF BEINGS -- NOT ONLY THE
COMPETENT PARTY, BUT THE DECENT
AND HONEST PARTY BY STUMBLING
AND BUMBLING AROUND, BY NOT
GETTING THEIR TIMELINE RIGHTS,
AMATEUR HOUR IS OVER.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT,
REPUBLICANS ARE DEMANDING THE
VISITOR LOGS FOR JOE BIDEN'S
HOUSE WHERE HUNTER LIVED, BUT
THE PRESIDENT CLAIMS THEY DON'T
EXIST, THIS IS NOT STOPPING THE
GRAND OLD PARTY FROM WINNING
MORE ANSWERS.
>> WE WONDER IF THE
SECRET SERVICE HAD RECORDS, NOW,
THAT'S THE NEXT QUESTION,
BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE
SECRET SERVICE PROTECTION, AND
HE WOULD ASSUME THAT THE
SECRET SERVICE WOULD VET PEOPLE
THAT'S WOULD BE ALLOWED ON THE
PREMISE OF THE DWELLING FOR THE
PRESIDENT IN THE UNITED STATES,
REMEMBER THE FBI WHEN THEY
RAIDED MAR-A-LAGO, THEY ALSO
TOOK THE SECURITY CAMERAS TO
LOOK AT SECURITY FOOTAGE, DID
THEY DO THE SAME WITH JOE BIDEN?
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JUDGE, IT
FEELS TO TIDY HOW SWIFTLY THE
TIDE IS TURNING AGAINST JOE,
IT'S LIKE A HIGH SCHOOL WHERE
THEY DECIDE THE POPULAR KID IS
NO LONGER POPULAR, DON'T YOU GET
THAT FEELING?
WHEN ADAM SCHIFF TURNS AGAINST
YOU?
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT IS
INTERESTING AS THERE IS A PART
OF ME THAT WANTS TO BELIEVE THAT
A LOT OF THIS IS BEING PROMOTED
BY THE DEMS, BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT DONALD TRUMP TO RUN -- THEY
DON'T WANT HIM TO RUN EITHER,
BUT THEY DON'T WANT JOE BIDEN TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT, SO HERE IS
THE ISSUE, GREG, THAT IS DRIVING
ME CRAZY.
ON NOVEMBER 2ND, THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS SAY THEY FIND DOCUMENTS,
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN A CLOSET
AT THE PENN-BIDEN CENTER,
PERSONABLE, WHY WERE THE LAWYERS
THERE?
WE DON'T KNOW WHY.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
DID IT SAY CLASSIFIED ON THE
OUTSIDE?
DID THEY OPEN IT UP?
ONCE THEY DID THAT, THEY SAY THE
NEXT WENT TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES, NOVEMBER 4TH, THE DOJ
COME NOVEMBER 9TH, THE DOJ SAYS
IT'S GOING TO DO AN ASSESSMENT
AND I GET, I GET BECAUSE THEY
ARE CORRUPT, THEY WANT TO HIDE
THE INFORMATION FROM THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, SO THEY DID NOT
SAY ANYTHING BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS, BUT THEY DID NOT SAY
ANYTHING UNTIL JANUARY THE 9TH,
THEY COULD HAVE A WEEK TO THIS
DURING CHRISTMAS WEEK, AFTER
CHRISTMAS WEEK, NEW YEAR'S EVE,
THIS COULD'VE COME OUT, MY
QUESTION IS, WHAT WERE THEY
DOING?
WHY DOES KARINE JEAN-PIERRE GET
OUT ON JANUARY 10TH AND SAY, WE
ARE ALL TRANSPARENT, WE HAVE
COMPLETED, I ASSUME IT HAS ALL
BEEN COMPLETED, TWO DAYS LATER
WE FOUND OUT THERE ARE MORE
DOCUMENTS.
SO THEY NOT ONLY DON'T HAVE
THEIR STORY STRAIGHT, BUT THAT
TELLS ME THAT THEY WERE DOING
SOMETHING DURING THOSE TWO
MONTHS, DURING THE TWO MONTHS I
CAN GUARANTEE YOU IN THAT HOUSE
WHERE JOE BIDEN SAID HE WAS
LIVING AND HUNTER SAID HE WAS
PAYING $49,000 A MONTH OF RENT,
WHICH IS MONEY LAUNDERING TO HIS
FATHER JOE, JOE SAYS HE ONLY
MADE $19,000 A MONTH ON THAT
HOUSE THAT HUNTER GAVE HIM
$15,000 A MONTH TO RENT, SO THEY
ARE ALL KINDS OF QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE GOING ON HERE AND
NOBODY IS ANSWERING THEM, WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO SAY IT'S NOT AS BAD
AS DONALD TRUMP, IT'S WORSE, AT
LEAST DONALD TRUMP WAS THE
PRESIDENT, THESE ARE ALL
OBAMA-ERA DOCUMENTS, AND I HAVE
TO SAY ONE MORE THING,
ANDREW MCCABE OF ALL PEOPLE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS, HE GETS THROWN
OUT OF THE FBI FOR LEAKING
DOCUMENTS, HE COMES AROUND AND
HE SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT'S, WE
REALLY -- WE REALLY SHOULD NOT
GIVE THE REPUBLICANS ANYTHING,
AND WE SHOULD LET THEM DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO, BUT
DON'T COOPERATE, AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT'S A HUGE GIFT TO
DONALD TRUMP, THAT'S ALL.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, DANA, I
GET THE FEELING THAT JOE BIDEN
IS LIKE THE FAKE I.D. THAT GOT
THE DEMOCRATS INTO THE BAR BY
DEMOCRATS I MEAN KAMALA HARRIS,
THEY DON'T NEED HIM ANYMORE.
SO THIS IS THEIR WAY OF PUSHING
THEM OUT.
>> Dana: I THINK NOW THEY
MIGHT BE STUCK WITH HIM, HIS
APPROVAL RATING WENT UP A LITTLE
BIT MORE AND THEY REALIZE THAT
THEY HAVE A BLOODIED PRIMARY ON
THEIR SIDE THAT WOULD BE PRETTY
BAD, AMERICANS USUALLY REELECT
THEIR PRESIDENTS, VERY UNUSUAL
NOT TO GIVE THEM A SECOND TERM,
AND I THINK UNTIL THIS HAPPENED
TO THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE A WALK
IN THE PARK AND IT MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT, BUT I DON'T SEE ANY
DEMOCRAT COMING OUT AND ACTUALLY
CHALLENGING THEM, IT IS GOOD FOR
THE REPUBLICANS, REMEMBER
JOE BIDEN SAID WE ARE GOING TO
BE THE RETURN TO NORMAL, WE ARE
GOING TO BE THE EVERYTHING IS
CONFIDENT, EVERYTHING IS FINE,
NO ONE HAS TO THINK ABOUT US OR
WORRY ABOUT US, AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY TURNING UP NOT TO BE
TRUE, ON THIS STORY THEY ARE
CHALLENGING THE AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWAL DEBACLE IN TERMS OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS FAILURE, THIS
IS SO INTERESTING THEY CONTINUE
TO EXTEND THE BAD NEWS CYCLE BY
HAVING IT OUT THERE, AND
MENTIONING SOMETHING HE SAID THE
TIMELINE KEEPS CHANGING,
SOMETHING THAT DRIVES THE MEDIA
CRAZY IS AT THE TIME LINE
CHANGES, BUT WAIT, YOU SAID THIS
AND NOW THIS AND NOW YOU'RE
LOOKING AT US, THAT DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE, WHY WOULD YOU HAVE
SAID IT?
YOU KNOW ON THE 18TH, AND THE
PRESS SECRETARY IS LIKE YEAH,
SHE CAN ANSWER ANY OF THOSE
QUESTIONS IN A WAY THAT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY I DON'T
KEEP A TIMELINE.
>> Dana: IT'S BETTER NOT TO
I THINK THAT THIS WILL GO
FORWARD, I THINK THAT THE DEMS
WILL LEARN THE HARD WAY THAT
THIS IS JUST SAYING, YEAH, BUT
DONALD TRUMP WHAT'S WORSE IS NOT
GOING TO CUT IT THIS TIME
AROUND.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW I REALLY
WANT TO SAY THAT THE WALLS ARE
CLOSING IN, BUT I KNOW THAT IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATING CNN.
>> Joey: THE WALLS ARE CLOSING
IN.
IF CUTTING THEM OFF AT HIS KNEES
HERE.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT PLAY
HERE FOR ME, AS AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN WATCHING THIS PLAY OUT,
THE FIRST IS FAIRNESS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, AND INVESTIGATE
DONALD TRUMP OR WHAT HAD
HAPPENED, INVESTIGATE BIDEN FOR
WHAT HAD HAPPENED, THEY SHOULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
VIOLATING PROTOCOLS THAT I WOULD
BE RUINED OVER AS A YOUNG
MARINE, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A
PRESIDENT THAT I VOTED FOR
TWICE, THAT IS TRUE.
AS A REPUBLICAN, DO I FEEL
BETTER ABOUT DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
IN A SAFE INSIDE OF SECURED
COMPOUNDS THAN I DO BEHIND
JOE BIDEN'S CORVETTE, OF COURSE
I DO, BUT BOTH OF VIOLATIONS OF
THE SAME RULE, INVESTIGATE THEM
AND PUT IT OUT THERE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
JAIL TIME ON THE TABLE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, BUT IF I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE SECOND
ISSUE THAT AS A PARTISAN REALLY
IS IMPORTANT TO ME IT IS THIS
FACT THAT MY BODY WHO LIVES IN
MY HOUSE ABOUT HALF THE TIME AND
LOVES TO PARTAKE IN GREEN
CIGARETTES POINTED OUT TO ME,
LOOKS AT ME AND MY GYM AT THE
BASEMENT AND SAYS, YOU KNOW,
THEY DO EVERYTHING THEY ACCUSE
REPUBLICANS OF DOING, AND HE
SAYS IT'S A LINE, BUT THEY CALL
US RACIST WHILE THEY ARE PUSHING
CRT AND FRONT OF THE LINE
EQUITY, THE CALL US WAR HAWKS
WHILE THEY DRONE AMERICAN
CITIZENS ABROAD AND FUND OUR WAR
AGAINST RUSSIA, THE CALL US
INSURRECTIONIST WHILE THEY ARE
BURNING CITY HALL M NOT ONLY
DOING THAT, BUT PUMPING UP
STACEY ABRAMS, THE OG ELECTION
DENIER, AND THEY DO ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT THEY ACCUSE
REPUBLICANS OF, THERE ARE JUST A
LOT BETTER AT COMMUNICATING IT
ON THE FRONT END, WE WILL GO GET
SOME BACKGROUND SO LET'S PRETEND
LIKE WE ARE NOT DOING IT AND
ACCUSE THEM OF IT, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, I KNOW YOU ARE, BUT
WHAT I MY, AND I DON'T THINK
THAT THEY WILL GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> Greg: HERE'S THE THING,
IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT KLOS
DON'T CROSS THE BLOOD BRAIN
BARRIER, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING, THIS IS NO LONGER FEELS
THAT PARTISAN.
>> Geraldo: FIRST OF ALL, I
WANT TO INVITE JOEY TO MY
BASEMENT FOR THE GREEN
CIGARETTES, I THINK HE OWES IT
TO ME.
ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
HERE WITH YOUR BUDDY THEN,
LISTEN, I STILL THINK THIS IS
ERIC HOLDER FAST AND FURIOUS,
HILLARY CLINTON AND BENGHAZI, IT
IS A BIG, BIG BOOM AND THEN IT
ALL GOES AWAY AND AT THE END OF
IT, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE THE PRIME
PROTAGONISTS HAVE EGG ON THEIR
FACE.
I THINK THAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT A
BUNCH OF NOTHING.
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT THERE
WERE DOCUMENTS IN THE GARAGE, I
DON'T THINK ANYONE HAS MADE THE
CASE THAT THEY WERE STOLEN OR
THAT THEY WERE GIVEN TO SPIES,
OR THAT THEY HAVE BEEN IMPERILED
OR THE NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, I
THINK THAT IT IS ALL ABOUT
PARTISAN POLITICS, AND ALL ABOUT
GOT YEAH, THEY WENT AFTER TRUMP
AND EMBARRASSED HIM, NO WE WILL
GO AFTER JOE BIDEN AND GET HIM,
AND THEY RATED DONALD TRUMP, WHY
AREN'T YOU READING JOE BIDEN?
THEY WILL USE IN THE SENSE AS A
POLITICAL BLUDGEON THAT IS ALL
ABOUT NOTHING.
>> Greg: HOW IS THAT WRONG?
WE ARE STARTING THAT.
>> Geraldo: THAT IS WHY I AM
NOT A POLITICIAN NORA MY
POLITICALLY CORRECT, I CANNOT
IMAGINE WHAT LIFE IS LIKE IF
THIS IS WHAT YOU DO ALL DAY IS
PURSUE THESE MEANINGLESS EMPTY,
IRRELEVANT SCANDALS ONLY BECAUSE
THE OTHER PARTY DID IT AND IT IS
PARTISANSHIP PURE AND SIMPLE,
AND WHEN I SEE THE OTHER
DEMOCRATS CHICKENING OUT AND
SAYING, OH, THE AMATEUR HOUR,
AND OH, MAYBE WE ARE BAD, IT
REMINDS ME SO MUCH OF RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
IT'S BEEN WHEN YOU ARE A LAWYER,
THIS IS IT AGAINST THE LAW, PURE
AND SIMPLE.
>> Geraldo: WHAT LAW?
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT LAW?
YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO TAKE
CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS
AND PUT THEM ANYWHERE
>> Geraldo: THEN HE WOULD HAVE
TO ARREST EVERY SINGLE --
>> Judge Jeanine: NOTE, TOO
MANY PEOPLE ARE IN JAIL, TOO
MANY PEOPLE ARE IN JAIL RIGHT
NOW FOR THAT, AND YOU KNOW WHAT,
THE WAY TO STOP IT IS TO START
ARRESTING.
>> Joey: NO YOU ARE REALLY
PROUD OF THE TIME YOU SPENT DOWN
RANGE AND I WONDER HOW YOU GO TO
SLEEP AND NOT RECONCILE WHAT YOU
SAID KNOWING THAT SOME IN THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN WOULD HAVE THEIR
LIVES THAT RUINED IT DOING
EXACTLY WHAT THOSE TWO MEN DID.
>> Geraldo: I DIDN'T FEND ANY
SERVICE PERSON ACCUSED OF THIS,
WITH MY DYING BREATH, I THINK
THAT IT IS RIDICULOUS.
>> Joey: I WANT TO SAY THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE THIS PROBLEM.
>> Geraldo: AND ANY CASE I
HAVE HEARD REFERENCES, ANY CASE,
IF SOMEBODY REALLY WENT TO JAIL
BECAUSE OF A NEGLIGENT HANDLING
OF A --
NEGLIGENT HANDLING, NOT
INTENTIONALLY --
>> Judge Jeanine: THE GUY WHO
SENT THE PICTURES TO HIS
PARENTS.
WAS THAT HIS NAME?
>> Dana: THE WOMAN I TALKED
ABOUT LAST WEEK WAS IN THE HOTEL